okay
you know live thank you very much
good morning ladies and gentlemen
members of the committee
members of the council and the general
public
um welcome to this meeting with the
community and resources
committee by the agenda
could be a short meeting we'll see how
it goes
first of all item one apologies for
absence
thank you chair yeah one apology
counselor wiseman
uh councillor hodgson will be
substituting
thank you uh item
two are the minutes of the meeting held
on the 22nd of march
um go through looking
for corrections
starting with at the bottom page three
four five
six seven
eight yeah counselor locks raised hands
yep yeah just a query on the fourth
bullet point down um
about the planning applications that
were going to be submitted
i noticed in the weekly list
there's an application being withdrawn
by torridge for two storage
um containers at riverbank car park
um is that in those
items bullet point are they replacing
one of those or was that one that just
slipped
them
yes please um i got shorts out next to
me we're not quite
we're not quite sure uh which
application counselor lock is referring
to so
if members are committee happy we'll
we'll look into that and circulate
a response it was on the weekly planning
list
this week on fridays being withdrawn
this one the two stories containers in
the council's car park
chair we need to get an update from
adrian as to whether
he's just withdrawing it to resubmit
another time and we'll provide a written
response for
for members if that's okay all right
thank you
okay move on page nine
page ten page
11 page 12
page 13. so we're happy with them
we have to go to a vote to accept them
he's joined us he's muted at the moment
four
sorry sorry four thank you councillor
bright
penciller bushby or ansel crazy
oh pencil dart or
canceler hicks or pencil
he's not present i did wonder councillor
james
or pencil laws or
penciller lock or hansel mcgrath
not present okay thank you tom
and councillor hodson oh
unanimous chair thank you
so we move on to item three public
contributions
i've not been told of any
have we any that's crazy there aren't
them
proper job any statements received
no statements either chair proper job
item 4 forward plan page 14.
you have it in front of you that's for
the next meeting
anyone anything to say about it
chair counselor darts raise their hands
yep
proper job cancel the dart
can i just ask what the brad with the ar
brackets they are i assume that's
initial
um what brad were these on there for
because i can't remember
no i i wondered that as well
chair it's shawnee and it it's
in relation to the uh ongoing
negotiations
in relation to the transfer of the
toilets in bradbury to the parish
council
and when uh when that recommendation is
ready come to cnr
i'm not sure whether it will be june but
it's certainly an item that needs to be
carried forward
thank you
anything else
proper job we can move on
item five declarations of interest
it's there to remind you if you have a
pecuniary or personally and
personal interest you must declare it
item six agreement over the agenda
between parts one and
two as far as i can see there's nothing
for part two but we reserve the right to
move into it should we have to
if we're discussing matters of finance
or personal to individual members of the
public or whatever
item seven urgent matters i have none
does anyone else have anything
nope right
item eight budget monitoring pages 15 to
16.
are you taking that one am i wheelchair
um you have um probably the world's
shortest report in front of you
essentially it's a very simple message
the simple message is
at quarterfree the council's financial
position improved by 443
000. we are still in a state of some
financial volatility as much as
much because we don't know what um
further support we will be getting from
central government
and the proposal is simply that we close
the financial year down which
my team are currently doing and when
we've got to the true position for the
financial year 2020-21
we make a considered decision to do what
uh to decide what to do with the surplus
that arises therein so
should we adjourn any decision about the
surplus as a quarter three and adjourn
it till we've actually got the full
position
for the financial year 2021.
and there's nothing more really to say
the recommendation in a nutshell is
don't count your chickens until they've
hatched
uh claire would like to sleep up right
claire
like to move the recommendation as lead
member did
comment on the report i think it is
a very sensible way forward so i moved
the recommendation as noted
that we defer any decision on the
allocation of the 2021
surplus until the accounts for this year
are closed
anyone else wishing to speak
i'll put it to the vote we have to put
it to the vote
thank you chair councillor brenton
are you me to counselor brenton
boar pencil bright
or councillor bushby or
ancelor christie or pence ladart
or pencil hicks for
blue james pencil laws
or counselor lock or
and councillor hodgson paul
unanimous chair proper job
right we move on to agenda item nine
the harbour board and the port marine
safety code annual report
i would ask you to bear in mind members
that
biddeford harbor gets caught by all the
rules and regulations exactly the same
as the very large harbors in this
country
so our officers have had to deal with
that accordingly
i don't know who's taking this one
richard is it i guess
yes chair i'll take this one
you happy me to proceed yes
so thank you members um the purpose of
the report
is to update and reassure members of
torridge's compliance with the port
marine safety code
and as such the chairman has written to
the
maritime coastal agency advising them of
such
now there's not a lot of work that's
been undertaken in the last 12 months
by the harbour master the harbour team
and janet as
janet williams the designated person and
to ensure that we are
compliant this included updating all of
our risk assessments
all of our safe systems of work staff
training
and and ensuring that their
qualifications
are continually up to date communication
channels with any activities
and that will increase more with the
updating of the new website
our staff implications um due to the the
person of a
standard crane driver and getting the
replacements trained
and also ensuring that our incident
reporting procedures
are um compliant as well
now as as the chair
as mentioned the port marine safety code
sets out the national standard for every
aspect of port marine safety with
imports and yes we are
we have to comply even though our
harbour isn't as busy as we'd all like
uh we are working towards increasing
trade but
we have to comply similar to the likes
of dover or some of the the busier ports
um and while we have written to the mca
advising them that we are in our view
compliant
um we will be expecting them to give us
an external order
almost like a cleansing check and then
we'll bring
forward any recommendations from them to
this community in the future
we don't know when that will be
but hopefully it'll be soon and once
again this
is the start of the work that uh
paul and janet have undertaken is that
we now need to continually
audit ourselves um and monitor our
procedures to make sure that we
continue to be compliant so the purpose
of this
report really is to note that uh
the recommendations and of the
designated person to hover board
of the harvard authorities continued
compliance with the port marine safety
code
and this was approved by the hoverboard
and the chairman of councillor hitch
like i said
by writing to the maritime coastal
agency
i'm happy to take any questions where i
can and if i don't know the answers i'll
get right back to you okay
open to the committee
counselor bright thank you chair
i just want to check the uh shipyard and
its associated rifts have been
considered
in the risk assessments because
obviously the nature of april shipyard
is quite different to
standard vessels that are going around
and also they have fabrication works on
board as well as
they do specific kind of procedures like
if they're towing barges with multiple
vessels
it's something that you know might slip
the net if you're not really
you know not really paying attention
you're just saying oh yeah it's just
fishing vessels i just want to make sure
that that's been considered
you're going to attack while we're
after shipboard is actually outside of
the harbour
area and the port of biddeford um we
still have the
the political responsibilities
um and any movements actually on the
estuary itself
uh with with boats or ships over a
certain size then we would enter with a
pilotage
but i would expect they would be
regulated by their own
systems of a company of such nature and
they would have to be compliant with
their own
risk assessments and say systems of work
it's outside our jurisdiction in the
main
yes it is chad thank you
councillor bushby
thank you chair i just did just a query
on page 18
where it refers to top of the page
designated person
must be appointed to provide independent
assurance i mean
presumably it's it's perfectly okay for
a member of torres staff to be that
independent person
because it doesn't sound independent if
you read it in that way
yes chairway we we've discussed that it
was legal and
while janna is an employee of charge
district so she has no direct
control or authority apart from this
particular role
um she's a wealth of health and safety
experience and qualifications
and ordered it as an independent
thank you no
no one else wishing to speak
here sorry ah councillor brenton sorry
sorry sir um yeah i was going to ask um
it used to be the case that
the new year's eve celebrations sort of
coincided with the harbor doing its sort
of annual
um sort of safety check at the same time
uh saving money um is that still going
to continue how does that work now
used to the port was sort of barricaded
off wasn't it
to do with something to do with health
and safety does that still continue
um obviously this year it passed it
hasn't with obviously
it was with the pandemic um but that
would be the same hopefully for next
year if
if if the celebrations continue yes
that's more of a um an issue for the
event itself
protecting from the people that gather
there but we
do actually uh use that as an as a time
where we can
run drills tests um on our system so i
would look that that will continue for
next year
thank you
anyone else wishing to speak
well this report is purely for noting i
don't believe it needs a vote
on it so if no one else is wishing to
speak
you have it noted in your memories
i think we can move on to the next item
agenda item
10 council tax hardship support
this will be of great interest to a few
people
thank you chair i'll be presenting this
and there's actually a small
presentation so hopefully tom can
there you there you are tom's produced
the first slide thank you very much tom
it's almost like you can read my
thoughts um i'll just go some background
i think members of this committee have
had a fairly similar presentation
as members of leadership and i have
changed it a little bit it's a very
short presentation i'll just try to get
the essence of it
so as background in response to the
pandemic the government announced
funding nationally
500 million pounds to support
economically vulnerable people and
households and the key point arising for
the guidance which accompanied the
funding
was all the funding was directed to
billing authorities such as torrid
and the government expectation was the
majority of the funding would be used to
provide additional council tax relief
alongside existing local council tax
support scheme so it's in addition to
what we always previously provided for
people on low incomes
and the government's strong expectation
was that billion authorities would
provide all recipients of working
age local council tax support during the
of financial year 2000 2021
with a further reduction in their annual
council tax bill of 150
pounds whether or not the taxpayer had
actually been affected by kovid 19
directly or indirectly
that shouldn't be taken into
consideration when assessing eligibility
for this reduction next slide please tom
so what happened we received 419 000
pounds of funding and we utilized 360
000 of that to reduce council tax
liability for people in local council
tax support of working age
that equated to about 2 400 cases at 150
pounds a time roughly as a rule of thumb
at any one time there's 2 000
people of working age in receipt of
local council tax support
um so the little table that you can see
at the bottom of the bar charts that
showed kind of how it could work as an
example
so our maximum liability we could of
relief we could offer was 75
so on the left hand side you've got the
council tax liability we award
we could award potentially for 75
existing scheme
then we could provide another 150 000
pounds of relief
under the council tax hardship scheme so
for a band day the bill would actually
come down from 1
300 pounds to 175 pounds
for people of working age in receipt of
full local council tax support
because of the government's hardship and
funding that we received in 2020-21 next
slide please tom
just as background the majority of
people of working age claiming local
council tax support within torrid did
not suffer a fall in their income as
rule of the pandemic and primarily
because they're not in the economically
active in the workplace i.e they're in
receipt of disability benefits so
they're not people who are generally
in and out of work so essentially the
150 pound counsel that hardship
reduction
for those client group which is the ones
in the light blue
was actually a financial windfall to
them in the main next slide please tom
so what's happening for 2021 well
nationally the funding's increased from
500 million to 670 million
however the funding has been allocated
to preceptors and billing authorities
based upon their share of the council
tax bill
and as members will be aware tourists
share the council tax bill is only about
eight and a half percent
and with the precept with the town and
paris councils it just
dips into 12 so therefore our funding
reduced from 419
000 pounds to 72 000 pounds the guidance
that accompanied the grant from the
government was that it was an unfin
unring fence grant so the council could
do what it wanted with
and it's aimed directly at supporting
councils to meet the anticipated
additional cost of providing local
council tax support scheme
in 2021-22 resulting from an increase on
employment essential what government was
predicting was that unemployment would
rise
more claims would come in for local
council tax support and therefore
councils would take less money in from
their council tax and
be suffering a financial loss outfits
its prime reason for giving us the
funding
it was not funding to be tran passported
to council tax payers in the same way as
the original 500 million was from the
previous financial year
um mcl mhclg expect the fund will
benefit economically vulnerable
households by enabling councils to
continue reducing their bills for the
least able to pay so what they didn't
want they didn't want councils making
their local council tax support schemes
less generous because they were
expecting more claims
and it enables authorities to continue
reducing council tax bills next year for
those least able to pay
for the next slide please tom so
what's the recommendation there is a
slide after this
uh the recommendations we allocate the
72 000 pounds we receive from government
to support a council type hardship fund
scheme
to focus assistance on those of working
aid claimants who have suffered economic
hardship as a result of the pandemic
and we adopt the council tax support
policy which is attached to operate
alongside the council's existing
hardship policies can have the next
slide please tom
so this the key point from the policy
that's been shared and circulated
are the scheme will take place in the
financial year 2020
1 22 only initially responded funding
will be restricted to the 72 000
provided by central government but would
be reassessed in light of the
council's overall financial position
during 21 22.
consequently the scheme may and be ended
prior to the close of the financial year
2021-22
depending on the volume of applications
received
the scheme will be limited to those of
working age
the maximum support that can be offered
is 500 pounds
or the outstanding council tax liability
whichever is the lesser
support will be restricted to the
financial years 2020 21
and 2021-22 council tax arrears prior to
this date
will not be considered for relief the
award of the council tax hardship
support
covert 19 will provide an application
process
applicants do not need to be in receipt
of working age local council tax support
to be eligible
support will be restricted to council oh
i've already mentioned that i haven't
i've put something in
there twice so just to reiterate it's
only for the financial years 2020 21 and
2021 22.
and the award of any council tax
hardship support will be discretionary
and the count the scheme will run
alongside the council's existing
hardship policy
and i think that's the last slide is it
tom
so any questions that's right
throw it open to members
yeah i don't know that dave is david
hurley on today this morning
no he's not counselor james like okay
well um i'll take the lead on that
then um unless there's any other
questions
basically um we i know we've put quite a
bit of work on this
and uh thank david hayes for what he's
done
david hurley's took a bit of a lead on
it claire and uh
council hudson and myself has joined in
and basically what we're doing is trying
to target
the money at those that have suffered
the work the biggest loss
um and if you take the fact that there's
only 72
000 if we've done it like we did before
the amount of money we could give
everybody on lcts would be fairly small
and of course as it said
that 50 of those on our cts
actually didn't uh require it so
um i said david you want to come back in
yeah i think really we should have um
included joe wells in some
thanks because i think joe wells did
quite a lot of the work and yeah just to
reiterate your point
yes i'll pass it on no but just to
reiterate as well that actually we've
just done in a
broad brush across the scheme we'd
struggle to give 30 pounds relief to
everybody so it's better to focus it on
those who've actually suffered the pain
so actually potentially we could give up
to 500 pounds
and if we just did a broad brush across
this game it'd only be like 30 pounds
thank you right so i'll just come in
with my apologies to joe
because i know she has done an awful lot
of work on it so um
i was hoping david was going to be here
but anyway um
nick wants to come in and then i'll move
to the recommendations
thank you yes um through the chair
through the chair if i may um
i may be i'm looking at this with a sort
of business head on or trying to
and if we go to uh to the second bullet
point
the initial funding um this is almost a
totally dead duck before it starts isn't
it because it does throw it back on us
at the end
by saying um looking at the overall
finances during 2122
we know we're nearly broke so i mean it
it's almost a non-starter isn't it we
can only we can do
so little or am i reading this
completely wrong
thank you chair
can i just come and share my crystal
ball isn't obviously as clear as council
or laws i
genuinely don't know what the financial
year 2021-22
holds for it does depend on a variety of
factors such as the number of visitors
who come
on our car parking whether we repeat the
planning application year we've had
and what support we get from government
i mean at the moment we've got
some financial support from government
for covid up to the first three quarters
i don't i generally don't know what
financial holds for
we've set a balanced budget hopefully we
achieve that balance budget
i think all we said here was if we got a
lot of applications
and perhaps if we the finances allowed
then we'd reconsider whether we could
extend the scheme
in those circumstances it's just an
open-ended
there's not a firm commitment it's just
to reassess depending on what the
financial position will be which at this
juncture
i really don't know
thank you for that uh reply it's quite
obvious that those in westwood we just
have to work harder
to support orage um thank you
uh steve harris
thanks jay um i guess it's just to make
a small point
um members will recall back a couple of
months now when you set the the budget
for this year and set the council
tax um this was a report
that uh members of whole council asked
to be brought back
to put in place um some levels of
support for those
uh members of the community who are
struggling with
council tax and job losses so as david
pointed out um
currently it's it's an amount that will
support
um to a greater level uh perhaps fewer
people
than would have been helped under the
the previous government scheme
but as we alluded to earlier once you
know
we can take a review of the support
that's being provided
once we get a clearer picture of uh the
applications that are coming in
um once the scheme is launched obviously
assuming members
approve the scheme
thank you on reading it i
come to the conclusion this is purely
officer decision
members have no decision on how the
money
at the moment it's joe would make the
decision based on the application if
somebody
disagreed with the decision i would be
the officer who would review
um joel's original decision
of course any member of the public can
refer it to elected officials as
as they wish but at the moment yes it's
an officer who would
process the applicant and make the
decision if somebody
uh disagreed with this decision then
they would appeal or
seek i would do a second opinion
thank you councillor james yeah uh
what's that is basic right the fact is
that um
we were asked to produce the how the
scheme was going to work within the
budget there is the 72
000 and as i said before council hodgson
myself
and council hurley have worked closely
with joe
and david on this council um
hurley will still be in a position as
lead member in that
to still discuss it with joe but the
decision will be
officer and there are appeal procedures
and basically what we're asking you to
do is to
agree to a scheme where we get much more
help to those who are in much more
trouble
um and our own financial position will
only be affected in so much as
as to whether we can put if we get more
applications and we can
cover with the 72 is whether we will be
in a financial position
to give any more um help to that scheme
but at the moment it's anticipated that
the 72 000
will cover the scheme because we're only
dealing with
half the number of lcts's um but we will
be
also faced with more people that have
been on further
so um i'm quite happy with it um
i'll move this chair and i'll second it
david do you want to come in sorry i was
just waving to turn the light on back in
my office because i've gone into
darkness i do apologize for that
distraction
yeah so i lost a little bit of that
of ken james actually was i the only one
who lost it or did everyone lose it
be honest bob most of them lose what i
say but
on this issue i think you might have
been the only one
um so we're in a position where uh
council bush has proposed it and i've
seconded it um
and the money is there and this is the
scheme that was requested
so slightly no-brainer
right well we have to put it to the boat
i think
i've got no one else wishing to speak so
off we go
thank you chair councillor brenton or
chancellor bright or
councillor bushby or dancer christie
[Music]
oh unanimous chair
proper job thank you we now move on to
item 11 the minutes of the harbor board
members have asked to see them here they
are um i throw it open to
comments and whatever
counselor bushby thank you
i know real issues but i think possibly
there's a couple of
typos on bottom of page 29
not that it makes a lot of difference
but if any anyone other than coaches are
reading them
they may find something to criticize
what does it know the the fourth
paragraph from the from the bottom
doesn't quite read write to me
uh where it says the designated person
advised of it possibly unless there's a
way i'm reading it advise
may be requested if you just read that
paragraph
it doesn't read correctly i don't think
i think it needs the word advised that
yeah and again
um the next paragraph down
the very last line however there are no
safety issues i think it should
should be four rather than so
would you agree
it says some areas of work carried out
starts there
over the marine safety plan and then the
last line however there are no safety
issues
so the dp content to carry forward it
should be full rather than so
should you not put in the word um can
before or can yeah as is as it is it
just doesn't read
correctly so the vpn
i think you need to put the word can
after dp
issues for the gp
can be to be precise
yeah or cross out so one but four
whatever those different ways of reading
it but yeah what's there isn't correct
anyway
just be tidied yes yeah
that'll be taken back to the harbour
board and put right
what about the contents thereof yeah
happy with that
i'll propose that if you want someone to
propose them i don't think we need to
do it oh it's just brought forward for
information
okay thank you um
well no comment
i said i thought it would be a short
meeting
i think we've been through the agenda
ladies and gentlemen that must be the
quickest cnr there's been for
generations
any other comment from anyone whilst
we're here
or i can declare the meeting closed